as we wait as we wait for the quizzes to
come
in. I know I've been say I've been
repeating this over and over again, but
your last class is two
weeks. People are talking.
So your last class is two weeks from
today, right? May 5th.
Okay, tomorrow tomorrow I'm going to
send you the details for the final exams
because as you know you have multiple
options. You have your attention please.
Okay. So tomorrow I should be you you'll
be able to get you at least you'll know
exactly what to expect in those last two
weeks. So now the key though is to get
the project done. I mean that is
critical because if you let it hang into
the last weekend, everything's going to
get jammed up. So you got to get the
numbers to me by Sunday, May 4th and the
project by May
5th. So today we're going to mop up on
dividend policy. We talked about, you
know, the the aspects of dividends that
you can look at, you know, across across
companies. So Leon will start me off.
You if you were to describe dividends
around the world, what's the word that
you would use to describe
them? Sticky. They're sticky. What does
that mean? Most companies in most years
pay what they did last year in
dividends. Second, they follow earnings.
They don't lead earnings. They're not
contemporaneous. They follow earnings.
So, companies wait to make sure they can
sustain dividends. Third, they're
affected by tax laws. Obviously,
investors get these dividends. How
you're taxed in the dividends will
affect what companies do. And finally,
increasingly in the US and it's starting
to spread across the world, dividends
are being replaced by stock buybacks.
Why? Because companies are feeling less
certain about the future. And the more
uncertain you feel, the more reluctant
you become to to start dividends because
then you're stuck with paying those
dividends. So today, what I'd like to
start with is essentially a framework
we've seen before. We looked at
companies moving through the life cycle.
We used to talk about capital structure.
Young companies shouldn't borrow money.
As you mature as a company, your debt
capacity opens up and as you decline,
you got to bring your debt down. You can
use the exact same framework to talk
about how much company should pay in
dividends. Let's start right if you look
at what a company can afford to a young
company can't afford to pay dividends.
There's nothing to debate here. Why it's
money
losing? And even as it starts to make
money, the reinvestment needs it'll need
to keep that growth going will mean its
cash flows are negative.
As companies mature, your capacity to
pay dividends will open up. Why? Because
your net income starts to become more
significant. Your reinvestment needs
become smaller. Your capacity to pay
dividend. But initially, what do
companies do? They deny. They say,
"Look, no, we're not." Because everybody
still wants to be a growing firm. So,
initially, when your capacity to pay
dividends opens up, companies refuse to
pay dividends. They hold on to the cash
hoping they can become young again.
takes about three, four, five years and
proddding for these companies to finally
wake up saying you're not going to be
young again. You have to start returning
the cash. Whether you do it in dividends
or buybacks is a choice that companies
have to make. But your capacity to pay
dividends opens up. Eventually, you
start paying dividends. And as you
become a mature firm, those cash returns
become more and more regular.
tomorrow's um you know I don't I know
you've been not been looking at the
weekly puzzle but I look at the 10
companies that bought you don't even
remember there was a weekly puzzle right
I'll send you the list of the 10
companies that did the most in buybacks
last year take a look at that list and
get a sense of where in the life cycle
you'd put those companies I'll give you
a
couple one of the largest buyer backs I
mean and this has been true for the last
seven years Apple has collectively
bought back about $600 billion ion
dollar of its own stock over the last
seven years. What does that tell you
about Apple? Clearly, the cash coming
and they can't use it. Return the cash
and the cash balance still goes up. That
tells you how much of a cash machine
Apple has become. So, you tell me where
your company's in the life cycle. I can
kind of guess whether your company
should be paying dividends or returning
cash. So, take a look at your company in
your project. Think of it in the life
cycle because it's going to give you
that framework just as as evidence of of
know and it's loose evidence. It's not
evidence that I would take. No. If you
look at dividend yields and payout
ratios across companies, what I've done
is I've broken companies down based on
expected growth. Lowest growth
companies, highest growth companies. No
surprise here. The lowest growth
companies tend to have the highest
dividend yields, the highest payout
ratios, and the highest growth companies
tend not to do
that. There's a value investing strategy
of buying big dividend paying companies.
There's nothing wrong with this
strategy. When you buy big dividend
paying companies, don't expect them also
to be growth companies. That's not going
to happen for the most part. Once in a
while, you might get lucky, but usually
when you look at dividend payments, they
reflect where in the life cycle and how
much growth is
expected. So, here are my five companies
and what their dividend policies look
like. I've measured both the yield and
the payout ratio. Remember, the yield is
dividends as a percentage of market cap.
The payout ratio is dividend as a person
of net income. If you take Disney, the
dividend yield, no whether you look at
the most recent year at least in 2013 of
the five year is pretty close as is the
payout ratio. But take a look at valet
the dividend yield and the payout ratio
in the most recent year looks really
really high. 6.45% dividend yield payout
ratio of more than 100% of net income.
But if you look at the average over the
five years, very different numbers. So
what is it about that's causing that
disconnect between what you see in
dividends in the most recent year and
what's happened over the last 5 years?
What's
changing? The dividends are sticky,
right? They're not changing. So what has
to be changing is the denominator with
Valle. The market cap is going up and
down. The net income is going up and
down. And the reason is not difficult to
find. It's a commodity company. When
iron or prices go up, its market cap
goes up. Its net income goes up. So when
you're looking at commodity companies
and you look at a dividend yield or a
payout ratio in a particular year, don't
be surprised to see a number that
doesn't make sense by itself, but you
look across time, it'll start to make
sense. The company in this group that is
clearly in trouble is Deutschbank. Its
payout ratio is 362% and unlike Val,
there's no iron or price coming back
here that's going to cause them to
recover here. And we'll take a deeper
look at this. Clearly, the company's
paying out more than it can afford to in
dividends. Everybody knows it. Investors
know it. The company knows it. To which
the obvious question is, if they know
it, why don't they do something about
it? We'll talk about why companies are
so reluctant to change dividends once
they're locked in and how that can put
them in a pathway to essentially going
bankrupt if they don't. In the case of
Do it, it might not be bankrupt. It
might be something else. But essentially
that pathway is is lined up because
you're refusing to pay change your
dividends. So here are the three schools
of thoughts thought and dividend policy
and they kind of cover the spectrum. The
first school of thought essentially says
there are no tax disadvantages to
investors between dividends and capital
gains. In other words, you're taxed
exactly the same way. And companies can
go out and raise equity with no issuance
cost. It doesn't matter how much you pay
in
dividends. You can pay high dividends,
low dividends. You can pay more than you
can afford, less than you can afford.
Sounds weird, right? Dividends don't
matter. Does this sound mildly familiar?
In the capital structure section, didn't
we see an argument that doesn't matter
how much you
borrow? You remember the the two people
who came
up Miller Muriglani one, Miller
Muruglani 2. Essentially, in a world
with no taxes, this is Miller Modiglani
as it relates to dividend policy. In a
world where there are no taxes on
investors, dividends and capital gains
are treated exactly the same and
companies can raise capital. If we lived
in a Miller Morgillani world, corporate
finance classes would be half as long as
they are today. Why? Because right after
the remember we did the hurdle rate in
the investment section. We could have
stopped there because it doesn't matter
how much you borrow. It doesn't matter
how much you pay in dividends. So I'm
going to take a deeper look at why
dividends don't matter in the
milligleani world. But that's the first
school of thought. It doesn't matter how
much you pay in dividends. The second
school of thought argues that if there
is a tax disadvantage associated with
receiving dividends for investors,
companies shouldn't pay dividends.
Dividends are bad. They reduce your
value. And you can see why, right? If I
tax you 70% on what you receive as
dividends and only 28% what you receive
as capital gains, it seems absurd that
companies should pay dividends. The
second school of thought says don't pay
dividends. So, first school says it
doesn't matter how much you pay in
dividends. The second school of thought
says don't pay dividends at all. Let's
cover the spectrum here. The third
school of thought says if your investors
like
dividends, it's like the customer is
always right in retailing. If your
investors like dividends, paying them
more in dividends is good because it
pushes up the price. See how convenient
this is for a CFO? No matter what you
do, there's an entire school of thought
backing you up, right? If you cut
dividends, you point to the second
school. Dividends are bad. If you raise
dividends, you point to the third
school. If you have no idea what you're
doing with dividends, you point to the
milligleion unit. There is truth in each
of these arguments, but each of them, I
think, misses a key piece. Let's start
with the first argument,
okay, on why dividends and and we'll
take a deeper look, but I'm going to
kind of synthesize how I think about
these three schools and you tell me
whether this makes sense. If a company
has a lot of cash flows coming in and
doesn't have a good use for those cash
flows, doesn't have investments, it
should return cash to shareholders.
Whether it does in dividends or
buybacks, I'm agnostic
on. If a company doesn't have cash
coming in or has lots of projects to
take, it shouldn't be returning much
cash. Now, of course, I've left kind of
undefined how I'm going to capture how
much cash is coming in and whether there
are good projects, but we'll fill in
those details. But first, let's take the
three schools of thought. Let's start
with the Miller Modiglani proposition
about
dividends. Let's say you're a company
that can pay out a $und00 million in
dividends. You have that's how much cash
you have. Let's say you choose to pay
out 250
million. Play out why in the real world
that's a problem for companies. When a
company pays out too much in dividends,
France, what's the first consequence for
the company?
So they'll have to go raise money,
right? But in the million word, what did
we say about raising new equity? No
cost. So basically, if you pay out too
much in dividends, you raise fresh
equity. And you can already see this is
not the real world because in the real
world, there are costs. But if there are
no cost you raise the equity you take
exactly the same projects you'd have
taken anyway. The other thing you could
have done rather than raise capital is
not take projects and in the millimei
world that doesn't happen either.
Companies take good projects they can
raise equity. So paying out too much in
dividends doesn't affect your value. It
might affect the share count. It might
affect the per share numbers but it
doesn't affect your value as a company.
Let's go to the other side. Let's say
you can pay 100 million in dividends and
you choose not to pay those
dividends. What happens? You have a 100
million in cash in your company. Right?
Now, normally when a company has a lot
of cash as an investor, what do you
worry about? That they might go out and
take some bad projects, have all this
cash to burn through. In the Miller
Modiglani world, that doesn't happen.
You just pick good projects. If there
aren't good projects, you don't
overreach. So, in the milligani world,
paying too much in dividends or too
little in dividends has no consequence.
That's why dividends don't matter. And
investors, if they get too much in
dividends, will get less price
appreciation, but they don't care either
because they're taxed in exactly the
same way. So, as a as a shareholder,
instead of getting 2% dividend yield and
10% price appreciation, you might get 5%
dividend yield and 7% price
appreciation, but you don't care because
the taxes are exactly the same. Think of
this as the limiting case for dividends.
Dividends don't matter in a word with no
taxes where you can raise capital at
essentially no cost. Where would we find
this word? Perhaps you took a really
large market cap company which has
access to capital. It can raise as much
equity as it wants and its investors are
all pension
funds. I'll say look I don't care how
much you pay in dividends. It doesn't m
So you can in exceptional cases you can
argue dividends don't matter. So that's
the first school. The second school is
based on a very simple reality. We
talked about this last class. Through
much of the 20th century in the US,
dividends were taxed at a much higher
capital much higher tax rate. So there's
the dividend tax rate. The black,
there's the capital gains tax
rate. So you can see if you go to
1964, dividends were taxed at 90%. That
was the highest tax rate for
individuals. Capital gains were taxed at
28%.
huge difference between dividend tax
rates and capital gain. So this seems
like a slam dunk. If you're going to be
taxed 60 70 80% on dividends and only
28% on capital gains, the argument is
why would you ever pay out
dividends? What's the flaw this
rationale? Because if you look at this
graph, it seems like companies that pay
dividends are reducing the value. What's
the flaw in in the
argument? That tax rate of 90%. What?
Who who who pays that tax
rate? Really wealthy people. Remember,
you have to hit the highest bracket to
get to 90%. If your investors are people
who make very little money, pay 15% tax
or an ordinary income, this might
actually get
reversed. But if you look at your
investors and they're all wealthy
investors, you're absolutely right. And
they're being taxed at 90%, you
shouldn't be paying dividends.
Now, one of the questions that you might
want to think about when you look at
your company is what kind of
shareholders invest in my company? What
do they think about tax? You say, "How
the heck would I know? I can't do a
survey." You can, but it's going to be
kind of meaningless. But there is
information that you can use to actually
reverse engineer at least guess what
kind of shareholders own stock in your
company. And that's by looking at what
happens on the X dividend day. Let me
step back. When you look at how
dividends get paid out by companies,
there are three significant dates. The
first date is the dividend declaration
date. That's when the board of directors
gets together and says this is what
we're going to pay in dividends in the
next quarter. It happens about 6 or 8
weeks before the actual dividend date.
The board gets together. News goes out
in the Wall Street Journal and investors
react. The dividends went up, they went
down. So that's the date the news of the
dividend goes out. About six weeks
later, there's a date called the X
dividend date. Anybody want to help me
out on what the significance of an X
dividend date
is? What does it tell you about about
dividends? What?
Yes, Mckit.
So what in the old days what what
companies used to do they used to close
the shareholders books at the end of the
X dividend date it was a physical book
and everybody who was on that list would
get a check mailed out to them. So if
you bought the shares before the X
dividend date you'd get the dividend. If
you bought them after the X dividend
date you wouldn't get the dividend. In
fact, when you used to read the old
price tables on the X dividend day,
they'd put an X against a stock to say
that that stock was X dividend the
previous
day. So on the X dividend day, ownership
passes from one person another if they
sell before the X dividend day. It's a
big day that one
day or if you buy the shares just before
the X dividend day, you get to collect
the dividend. You this sounds like an
easy way to make money, right? All you
have to do is buy every company just
before the X dividend day, collect the
dividend because you'll own the X
dividend day, sell the day after. What
am I missing in this strategy? I mean,
if it's that easy to make money,
everybody should be doing it. If I Yes,
runs. It doesn't effectively get
subtracted, but the market price will
drop on the X dividend day, perhaps by
the dividend. Drops by the dividend,
you're completely neutral, but there's a
price drop. Will the price drop be
exactly equal to the dividend? Not
necessarily. And that's where taxes come
in. Let's play a game. Let's assume that
we're all investors in a company. Let's
say we all bought stock in this company
for
$5 years ago. Why did I make that five
years ago, Derek? What what's the
significance of putting in the five
years
there? It's it's also greater than one
year, which is the long-term capital
gain. So, in a sense, you are holding
stock for the long term. So, if you sell
it, you're going to have to pay capital
gains taxes. Tomorrow is going to be an
X dividend day, and the company is
expecting to pay a dividend of 50 cents.
Remember, there's no uncertainty by the
time you get to this point because the
board declared the dividend 6 weeks ago.
So, tomorrow you know for sure that if
you if you own the stock, you get 50
cents. If you sell the stock, you lose
the 50 cents. And I give you a choice
between selling before the X dividend
day, PB, or waiting and selling after
the X dividend day. Let's look at the
cash flows you would get as a
shareholder. If you sell before the X
dividend day, you're going to get PB,
the price before the X dividend day.
You'll have to pay capital gains taxes
because you bought the stock for a price
lower than that a while back. So, let's
say the price before the X dividend is
$8. You'll have to pay capital gains all
and you won't get the dividend. If you
wait through the X dividend day, you
will get a different price. And I
haven't told you what the price is.
Let's say it's PA. You'll have to pay
capital gains taxes on your capital gain
based on that price. But you'll also now
get a dividend on which you will have to
pay ordinary taxes. So you're given a
choice, right? You can either sell
before or sell after. And your cash
flows are going to be the cash flows
with just the capital gains if you sell
before and the cash flows with the
dividends if you sell after.
If this is higher than this for every
shareholder, in other words, every
shareholder get more by selling before
than waiting, what's going to happen in
the market? You're going to get a wave
of selling before and the price is going
to get pushed down. If if for everybody
waiting is going to give you a higher
cash flow, nobody will sell. So in
steady state for the for most investors
not for every investor you got to be
neutral between selling before and
selling after which is a fancy way of
saying the cash flows from selling
before have to be equal to the cash
flows from selling after for you to be
indifferent. So 80 90% of shareholders
this has to be true. If you take that
and work it through you get a very
simple equation on what should happen in
the X dividend day. If you have the same
tax rate on dividends and capital gains,
the price drop should be exactly equal
to the
dividend. If your dividends are taxed at
a higher rate than capital gains, the
price drop will be smaller than the
dividend because you'll accept a lower
number because pre-tax. No, the the tax
rate will capture the difference. If
your tax rate on dividends is less than
the tax rate on capital gains, there are
some countries where this is true, then
the price drop is going to be greater
than the dividend.
So you look at the X dividend day, you
look at the dividend, you look at the
price drop. By looking at that ratio,
you can guess what kinds of shareholders
own stock in your company. So if you
were to list dividends and capital gains
are taxed equally, the price change has
to be exactly equal to the dividend.
Dividends are taxed at a higher rate.
Price change will be less than the
dividend. And if dividends are taxed at
a lower rate than capital gains, the
reverse is going to be true.
This is actually something you can test
empirically, right? You can look at the
data and say what is true for my company
looking across multiple X dividend days.
So in the early 70s uh two two
professors at NYU know Elton and Gruber
they both wrote almost all of their
papers together. So they became you know
they were considered almost a pair
whenever you looked at a paper it said
Elton and Gruber. one of their most
widely cited papers. Here's what they
did. They took every US company looked
at the X dividend day and looked at the
price drop as a person with dividend.
And in their f in their study, they
basically found that across all US
companies, the price drop on the X
dividend day was roughly 78% of the
dividend paid. So if you pay a dollar in
dividends, the price drop was
78. What's that? What does that tell
you? tells you that investors at least
collectively pay a higher tax rate on
dividends than on capital gains. And if
you looked at the tax code, that pretty
much was true. That was in the early
'7s. Then in 1981, you got the Reagan
tax cut. The highest tax rate on
dividends dropped to 50%, the highest
tax rate on capital gains dropped to
20%. The price difference, the the the
tax rate difference had become smaller.
And a study that happened in the early
80s discovered the price drop had now
become 85 cents for every dollar in
dividend. So as the tax rate difference
become smaller, you're seeing the price
drop become larger as a percent of
dividend. Then you get to the 19 in 1986
there was a brief period where the tax
rate on both dividends and capital gains
both became
28%. That's the first phase the only the
only phase in the 1900s where this was
true. study that was done then found
that the dividend change was
90%. I'm sorry, the price change was 90%
of the dividend. But shouldn't it be
100% with the
tax? They're taxed at the same rate. So
if you're taxed at the same rate on
dividends and capital gains, it looks
like investors still attach a tax
disadvantage to dividends. So even if
you're taxed at the same same rate, what
is it that makes dividends more
problematic for you as an investor than
capital
gains? The tax rate is the same. Anybody
want to give that a shot? How do you get
tax on
dividends? I did my taxes a week ago.
Why? Because I had to. I hope you did,
too. Right?
So when you did your taxes, if you have
any savings left, NY, you might have
sucked all of that o off. But if you had
savings left in some, and you received
dividends, you had to report it as
income last
year. You couldn't say, "Look, I didn't
take the cash out. I'm not paying taxes
now." You're taxed on dividends when
they're paid
out. As opposed to capital gains, when
do you get
taxed? Only when you sell.
So do you see how this plays out, right?
Even though the tax rate is the same
with capital gains, you have this
optionality of being able to wait for a
right time to take the capital gains
taxes. What would be a right time? One
might be when you take, you know, a year
that you don't make much money. Your
income is low. What's the other great
time to take capital
gains? When you
die. And I'm I'm not being morbid
because when you die, you get a one-time
deal where every investment in your
portfolio gets marked up to its market
value, and you're not taxed on your
capital gains. It's a one-time as an
investor. You don't get to enjoy it, but
hopefully other people will. So, if
you're 83 years old, you have a lot of
capital gains. For God's sakes, don't
sell everything now and collect the
capital gain and pay the taxes. wait it
out in spite of the fact that the tax
rates are the same and this is true
today that dividends and capital gains
are tax at 23.6% at the highest tax
rate. I'd much rather have capital gains
and dividends because I get that
optionary. So if you take a look at your
company and you look at the the X
dividend day, you can at least get a
sense of what kinds of investors hold
stock in my company. What do they think
about dividends versus capital gains?
But let's take this the next step. Let's
assume that on
average the price change on the X
dividend day is less than the dividend
and you're a taxexempt
investor. Who's tax exempt pension funds
for instance? Can you think of a way in
which you can exploit this difference to
make money? Derek, how would you take
advantage of it? I'm giving you three
choices. You can invest in the stock for
the long term. Does
that I don't think that takes advantage
of the X dividend day. It's got nothing.
But you can either sell short, but that
sounds tricky. Or you can buy the stock
just before the X dividend day, collect
the dividend and sell it just after. Do
you see the benefit of doing this? You
collect the dividend, your price will
drop, but because it drops less than the
dividend, you keep the difference. It's
actually a strategy called dividend
capture or dividend arbitrage. It's
widely practiced especially by taxexempt
investors on large dividend paying
stocks companies like Coned or some bank
stock like Cityroup. You get these
investors coming in just before the X
dividend day and you see it in the spike
in the trading
volume on or just before they're buying
the shares and they would sell right
after. So here's how it plays out as an
example. Let's assume you have a company
and it is going to go it's trading at
$50. close of trading May 3rd. May 4th
is going to be an X dividend day and
it's going to pay out a dollar in
dividends. And based on this company's
past history, and that's all you have to
go
about, your price drop is expected to be
90. So to make money, here's what you go
out and buy a million shares of XYZ
stock at $50 per share just before the X
dividend day. You weigh out the X
dividend day. You collect the million
dollars in dividends. You sell the
stock. It's true you will lose 9 90 you
know 900,000 but you keep the difference
of a
100,000. Already you can see you have to
do this in tens of millions of shares to
make money. Right? If you bought a,000
shares and you tried to do this even as
a tax exempt investor you make so little
money it's not worth it. So dividend
capture is practiced by big
institutional investors who are tax
exempt. Is it immoral or unethical? No.
It's got nothing to do with the morality
or ethics. Got to do with the fact that
you have different tax rates across
investors and they're trying to exploit
it on the dividend capture day. So while
Japanese insurance companies would come
to the US and play this game just on X
dividend days because they were not
taxed on either the dividends or the
capital gains and you tried to take
advantage of the difference. In the
process though you will make the
difference
smaller. Is there any risk in the
strategy
friends? And what what could happen on
May 4th then causes your bestlaid plans
to go to hell in a hand
basket. It could be like a you know
remember April 31st or March 31st when
the tariffs were announced.
Let's say that was your X dividend day.
You know, everything lined up based on
historical averages. You say the price
is going to drop 90% of the dividend and
the market is down 6%. What's your stock
going to be down by? Definitely a lot
more than 90%. If you're going to do
this, do this on scale and do it across
time and lots of companies. There's a
story in the late 1980s of um I think um
Washington statebased you know somebody
managed a state portfolio and he'd read
this this work on how you could take
advantage and he decided to take all
this money 1987 October 19th and put it
into one stock that was paying a big
dividend that was of course the day the
the market was down 22%. You almost
wiped out the portfolio trying to do it.
So you're going to do dividend capture
do it in scale. do it across companies
and expect the law of large numbers to
help you. But it's definitely not. So
that's why I would call it dividend
arbitrage because arbitrage means it's
riskless. It's a strategy. It's risky.
So it's more dividend capture with risk
associated with it. But if you do it in
on enough companies, you'd probably walk
away with a few million dollars in
profits. So let's talk about some
reasons companies give for paying
dividends. And I'm going to start with
bad reasons first because I've heard
them. Here's the first one. That when
investors receive dividends, because
dividends are more guaranteed than
capital gains, they will reward your
stock by paying you a higher price. It's
called a bird in the hand, fell.
Basically, you got the bird in the hand
and you essentially say because I've got
dividends and they're more certain, I
will attach a higher
price. In theory, you can make the
argument, but it's a testable argument.
But because if this were true, what
should we expect to see in the market
prices of companies? If you compare
across companies based on dividends, if
investors reward companies that pay big
dividends, what should we expect to see
in the market as the stock prices of
companies? If you look at them relative
dividends, you in other words, high
dividend paying companies should trade
at much higher multiples of earnings
than low dividend paying
companies. You don't even have to look
at the data to know that that is not how
the market is working right now,
right? Nvidia pays no
dividend. Cityroup pays a big dividend.
You don't even have to dig deeper to
know, hey, investors don't go out and
reward you for paying dividends because
they give up something else.
So, I've heard CFOs say, "If I pay a big
dividend, markets are going to reward me
for paying a big dividend." I don't see
the evidence for that. But that's a bird
in the hand fallacy that you think
investors will reward you. And remember,
the choice they're making is not between
dividends today and expected capital
gains way out in the future. It's
dividends today versus the price drop
today. So, it's actually a onetoone
comparison. So, you don't get any
benefit for paying dividends. Here's the
second one. We had a good year and
because we have a good year and lots of
cash flows, we're going to start paying
dividends this
year. What's the problem with this
logic? You have a good year. Of course,
you have lots of cash flows. You start
paying dividends. You So, what are you
stuck
doing? You So, you had a good year as a
company. You have lots of earnings and
cash flows. You start to pay dividends.
This year, you can afford to, right? But
what have you kind of committed? You got
to pay them next year. and the year
after. And if you're a company that has
good years followed by bad years, God
help you, right? Because next year then
you're stuck paying the dividend. What
do you have to do? You have to go out
and raise capital. And unfortunately,
you don't live in the Millimani world.
There's a cost to raising capital that
is pretty substantial. It's the issuance
cost. It's higher for stocks than bonds.
It's higher for small companies and big
companies. This is how much you leave on
the table when you go out and raise
capital as a company. And you can see if
you're a really small company, you're
going to be giving up 7, 8, 10% of
whatever you raise when you raise
capital. You don't want to be stuck in
the cycle of going out and paying big
dividends in good years, raising equity
in the next year, and hoping things even
out because there's a leakage in the
cost that's going to drain the value of
your company.
So when you look at a company and you
look at its capacity to pay dividends,
you got to look at the long term. Not
just what you did last this year, but
whether you can sustain those earnings
for the long
term. So let's talk about good reasons
for paying dividends. So those are the
two bad reasons. There are three good
reasons for paying dividends. The first
is what's called the clientele effect. I
was saying on dividend policy, you get
the stockholders you
deserve. What does what does it mean
when you start to pay dividends? You get
investors who like your dividend policy.
If you don't pay dividends, you get
investors who like the fact that you
don't pay dividends. And over time,
those are going to be the stockholders
in your company. So, we'll talk about
the clientele effect and how it plays
out because it's going to have a big
role in how you get stuck on dividend
policy. The second is that dividends can
be used as a
signal. I'm wary of signaling stories,
but our life is full of signals we send,
right? I notice nobody's wearing a suit.
You know what that tells me? None of you
have interviews today, right? Why do we
wear a suit to an interview? Suit is,
especially the middle of summer, we have
to wear a suit. It's an incredibly
uncomfortable garment to wear. Right?
You're signaling to the interviewer,
look, this is how much I care about the
job that I'm wearing this really
uncomfortable outfit to talk to
you. Signaling basically is when you do
something, people read into what you do
and expand on that. We're going to talk
about how dividends can operate as a
signal. The story that's often told is
dividends are a positive signal. If you
increase dividends, we'll talk about
that story. But then I'm going to open
the door to can paying dividends be a
negative signal, right? And the problem
with signaling stories, you can cut both
ways. And there's a third reason, which
is, and it's not a noble reason, you
might pay dividends to rip off your bond
holders. We'll talk about why as bond
holders paying dividends hurts you. But
if you don't constrain shareholders,
they can actually rip you off by paying
more and more in dividends. So let's
start with the first of those
stories by looking at the clientele
effect. This is actually a very old
paper from the 1970s and unlike much of
academic research was really creative
paper. Here's what it did. It took a
stock called citizens utility. It's a
it's in northern New York. It's a it's a
traditional regulated utility that paid
big dividends but it had two classes of
shares. Now normally when you say two
class of shares what separates the two
classes like in Facebook and
Google it's voting rights right these
shares had the same voting rights. What
set them apart was how dividends were
paid on each class. So this part of the
class is going to get the class A shares
and you're going to get a cash dividend
of a dollar per share. This part of the
class is going to get class B shares and
instead of giving you a dollar in
dividends, I'm going to give you a
dollar in stock dividends. What does it
mean? You don't get cash in the mail.
You get more shares in the company. And
I'll also give you the option to convert
into class A shares anytime you
want. You see what the choice here is?
You can either receive the dollar in
cash dividends or a dollar in price
appreciation because you can convert at
any point in time. And I'm asking you
which one would you rather have. This
was 1970s. Highest tax rate on dividends
was 70%. Highest tax rate on capital
gains was
28%. If this were a world that financial
economists essentially assumed
rationality in, which class of shares
should trade for more? class of shares
that gets the cash dividend. The one
that gets a price appreciation of the
same
amount. The price appreciation shares
should in this case every single time
period the cash dividend shares traded
at a premium on the shares that got the
price
appreciation. You think that makes no
sense and it's by itself it doesn't make
sense. But here's what we were missing.
Do any of you own shares in regulated
utilities? I don't and most of us don't.
Why? Because they tend to be boring.
They're like bonds with a little bit of
price appreciation. But somebody must
own them, right? So who are the two
groups of people own who the biggest
shareholders in regulated
utilities? One is pension funds because
they might need the cash. The other is
older people, poorer people, people who
might not have other. So to them, this
cash flow actually makes a difference.
The check in the mail that they use to
cover whatever their expenses
are. They don't pay much in taxes. So to
them, the tax issue doesn't come. That's
a clientele effect. You pay big
dividends, you're going to attract a
certain kind of investor into your
company. And that investor likes those
dividends. They don't want you to cut
dividends because of some tax story
because they don't care about the tax
story. In fact, this study on on citizen
utility was replicated on I think eight
or nine Canadian utilities that had
exactly the same structure of cash
dividend shares and price appreciation
shares. In every single one of the
Canadian utilities, the same phenomenon
played out that people paid more for the
cash. So when somebody says investors
don't like dividends, that's not a
statement you can make, right? Most
investors don't like dividends, but
there are some investors who do. And if
those are the investors in your company,
you better keep feeding them the
dividends because that's why they bought
your
stock. So when you look at the clientele
explanation, the evidence basically is
you look at what a company pays in
dividends, you can reverse engineer from
it what kinds of investors own shares in
that company.
So if I asked you without even looking
at the who own shares in
Palunteer, it's not going to
be old poorer people. It's not going to
be pension funds. It's going to be
people who want price appreciation and
if you pay them a dividend, they're
going to be pissed off because it gives
them a tax consequence and that's not
why they invest in
Palunteer. You take Coned and you look
at their shareholder base, it's going to
be very different. So when you look
across stud at studies that look at
shareholder bases, you see this
reinforced. Companies that pay a lot in
dividends and have older and poorer
investors and taxexempt investors like
pension funds. Companies that don't pay
dividends tend to have richer, younger
investors who really don't want the
dividend. They want the capital gain.
I know this this is kind of tough page
to read, but this is from a study that
looked at the dividend yields of
companies and ran a regression against
the beta of the company, the age of the
investors in the company, the income
level of the company essentially to see
if this clientele effect plays up and
for the most part it got reinforced.
Older investors tend to pay high div buy
high dividend yield stocks. Wealthier
investors tend to avoid dividends, want
lower dividend yields, and the effect is
much stronger if the difference between
the dividend tax rate and the capital
gains tax rate is larger. There is a
clientele effect and it gets stronger
and deeper if the tax rates start to
vary. So there is a clientele effect and
every one of your companies in your
project has an investor base. We can at
least guess. You might not be able to
say categorically, but at least start to
guess what kind of investors hold shares
in my company. If your company's never
paid a dividend, my guess is younger,
wealthier, higher tax rate investors. If
your company pays big dividends, it's
going to be older, poorer pension funds.
By itself, you might say, "Who cares?"
But it is going to affect how you think
about dividend
policy. But once in a while though, this
can get you into trouble.
Through much of the
1900s, phone companies were regulated
utilities. Marbel, the original AT&T,
the monopoly in 1981 was one was broken
up into seven regional phone companies
and they all paid huge dividends. Why?
Because the investor base they got from
AT&T was older, poor, taxexempt, wanted
the big dividends. Wasn't a big deal
though, right? Why? because they were
regulated due to these nice predictable
earnings so they could afford to pay
large dividends and not face the
consequences. Then you get to the 1990s
and these phone companies discovered
their monopolies were getting shakier.
Why? Because you had cell phones and
smartphones enter the mix and you no
longer controlling the process the way
you used to. Your old regulated
utilities now become more technology
company than utility. So, I'm going to
put you in the position of the CEO of a
company that has historically paid huge
dividends, but you've been able to do it
because you had nice predictable
earnings. You were regulated, but now
the world has shifted and you've become
this riskier technology company. And I'm
going to give you the choices you face
because clearly your existing dividend
policy no longer fits and you have to
make a change. Here are the things you
can do. One is you can go in front of
your shareholders and courageously
announce that you're going to cut
dividends because you're now a riskier
company with more
uncertain. What do you think's going to
happen when you get in front of your
shareholders? Who are your
shareholders? A lot of older investors,
taxexempt investors who like the
dividends count on your dividends. And
what are you telling them? You're going
to cut their dividends. You're not going
to make it out of that room
alive. But you've been courageous.
you'll die a nice noble death,
right? The second is to continue to pay
the dividends that you used to and go
out and you know and and and defer the
investment in this new technology
business. Now, so what's going to happen
to you if you do
this over time? You're going to lose to
the competition because you're not
investing enough. And a lot of telecom
companies in the early '90s chose that
path. They basically said, "Hey, we
can't get out of a dividend policy, so
we're going to defer or not make the
investments." The third choice is to
continue to pay the dividends, take all
those investments, and go out and issue
new equity to cover the
difference. This way, it looks like
you're having your cake and eating it
too, right? You're continuing to But
there's a problem. Issuing that new
equity, if you remember, comes with that
8% 10% cost. So, quite a few telecom
companies chose this path.
Verizon. Now, basically, you look at the
1990s and then you get to a fourth
choice. And this is a choice that I'm
surprised more telecom companies did not
adopt. Do anybody guess what the fourth
choice could be that you could basically
have this risk? Because let's face it,
what's your problem? You have a core
business that's nice regulated,
predictable earnings on which you're
paying a lot in dividends. But you have
a growing risky
business where your cash flows are more
uncertain, maybe more negative. You
can't pay dividends, right? They're both
in one
company. Is there a fix? You could do a
spin-off of just your risky
business. AT&T did this with their Bell
Labs. Bell Labs, remember, used to be
was a legendary R&D powerhouse that AT&T
funded with its cash flows from its
monopoly business used. I mean, their
offices still around. I think they had
more Nobel Prize winners working at Bell
Labs at one point in time than any
university in the
US. In the 1990s, AT&T spun off Lucent
at the when the dot boom was happening
because people wanted technology
companies.
Lucent had the risky, you know,
research-driven business, AT&T would
have the form. Looks like the perfect
thing to do, right? The one mistake AT&T
made was when it spun off Lucent, it
made Lucent continue to pay dividends
like AT&T had. If they had done this
right, what should they have done? They
should have done the spin-off of Lucent
and said, "Lucent will pay no dividends.
It's a risky business. we're going to
give you a ch chance as AT&T
shareholders to switch your shares if
you want to. Many of them might have
said, "No, we're not interested. We'll
stay at AT&T." But there'd be a new
group of investors that come into Lucent
would have been much more inclined to
accept the fact that as a risky company,
it couldn't pay dividends. So, if you're
going to do a spin-off, make sure that
that spin-off is independent enough in
terms of dividend policy that it can set
a dividend policy that better
fits. Many pharma companies face that
choice, this choice right now. because
there is a core business that's nice and
healthy that can pay dividends and
there's this risky business on the
side of research where you can't pay
dividends perhaps there's an there's a
pathway you to separate the two Abbott
Labs did this with ABV and basically
separate into two companies so
possibility to explore if your business
is
changing let's stop there when we start
next class we'll start uh we'll talk
about how dividends can operate as
signals but I will send you an email
when your quizzes are done. You can come
pick them up and know go from there.